did you see that clip going around with
amber heard snorting coke on the
yeah
i mean i get my news from tmz and they
said that was absolute [ __ ] did you
see it though
i have not been she looked like she's
watching that
yeah did you see this she definitely did
not do cocaine on the stand no yeah i
don't know but she's that crazy i'm not
talking out of school because the guy
put it in his book if you want to see
somebody doing cocaine on tv during a
super bowl
uh thomas hollywood henderson
of the uh dallas cowboys you have to
read his book his book is [ __ ]
unbelievable the guy was doing he was
basically lawrence taylor before
lawrence taylor because of drugs he
messed up his career so that's why
lawrence taylor looked like he fell out
of the sky like there was nobody there
was no like link you know like the bands
it's like this band did this then they
did oh that's where they came from it
was like lawrence taylor just came from
outer space but like like hollywood
henderson was a linebacker he like
returned like a uh like a kickoff to
open like uh super bowl 10. like nobody
did that [ __ ] and he almost got a
touchdown
and um he was doing coke in the 70s
before people knew how to do cokes it
was just raw
he was like cutting it up with like a
matchbook or something and like his
[ __ ] nose was so [ __ ] he had a hole
in his nose
yeah so what he would do before a game
was he would just pack his nose with
cocaine so it was numb
and then he would go out and play and
then during halftime he'd be blowing his
nose as tom landry the straightest lace
guy ever with like a fedora looked like
he was on like dragnet would be telling
him what to do in the half and he would
be in there blowing his nose and then
repacking it
with cocaine so anyway when the second
time the cowboys played the steelers in
super bowl 13
he had cocaine and water and remember
those vix things when you had a cold and
there's footage of him going like that
and then people think he has like hay
fever or something he's actually [ __ ]
blowing lines in the rose bowl
during the super bowl
damn you ever just pack your hole with
cocaine back in the day
i discovered that i had the whole
uh it's called a deviated septum and i
discovered it when i was in the psych
ward
like days after my intervention
i just fortunately
have been clean and sober ever since
then how did i discover i just thought
you went to an ears nose and throat
doctor when they flash
i've taken pictures where i'll put the
flashlight on on my cell phone and stick
the flashlight in one nostril head
[ __ ] it really does that yeah you got
the hollywood bowl spotlight coming out
the other one
yeah
yeah
it's crazy but it just i forget how but
uh but once i discovered it like
i i managed to thread my nose with the
shoelace
knoxville came to visit me in rehab the
glass is always half full
this is really sad or
[Laughter]
and opportunity
it's pretty cool yeah that's gonna be a
lot of cocaine used to burn a hole
through your nose right yeah yeah i
didn't [ __ ] around man i
i i i was pretty strong in the in the
drugs department
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]